刷了两个小时视频一件正式没干
我告诉你这不是你的问题
这是大脑的问题
而且这个不但不是坏事还是好事
今天一条视频告诉你怎么把坏事变好事
刚才我们说了吗
这个人的这个大脑
他说是肚子
生存的原因
一旦予斗威胁
他就害怕
就躲避
万一出现一个斗京蒙湖怎么办
所以他就讲成这样一个习惯
碰到困难了
碰到那个挫折了
碰到恐惧了
他就会躲
所以如果一件事很困难
然后这个结果的话可能会遭到一些批判
人们通常就会选择
我不说我就干点是吧
别耍个手机
只是在事
那怎么办呢
我告诉你方法就是
千万别从山底下
还退着这个石头光山上走
跑到山底上
就拿小石头
往下滚
具体怎么做
首先低度
别想
直接行动
这是八个
就是人不想多想做一件事
我一直行动不就来
注意在想和行动之间
你可以考大个
只要你想做一件事
别想了直接做
比如说
我要去跑步怎么办
千川鞋下楼
哪逃我走两步
我家就了对吧
我要看书
我先把书打开
我要写东西我先把边界汽打开
对吧
你关键我写两字
反正我是
企业了
技术这句话
行动是动机的原因
不是动机的结果
所以当你想做一件事的时候
先企动
先把鞋传上
你把我走多少步
这是第一个
第二个
用系统
而不是用意力
什么叫用系统呢
我给大家举个小例子
就今天我在直播的时候就有一个朋友
就跟我说书子跟我
我一会拖牙任务很难受
我说为什么呢
他说你看我每天
我想拍短片
我不知道拍点啥
我也不知道怎么拍
我就说短片
因为我刷选题
例子刷就刷了还要是
然后来说
那算了明天在拍拍
明天又是这样
就我可怎么办的
我说你知道这是什么
这就是你
你退的事都上山
啥意思呢就是你拍短片
跟你拍你不会
你本身这个技能就
不会营有点累
对吧
然后你会发泥拍完以后
你还拍照我点
而你还怕别人评价你
辛苦半天
最后那个结果就这么一丢丢
对吧
这就是退的石头上山
一个重点的方法是什么
跑到三里面上
先手出一个雪球
然后往下滚雪球
怎么做呢
就拿拍那个短片来说吧
现在有一种方法
什么方法呢就是你去评论
评论人家的
这这视频下面评论
评论完这个内容是可以发成
短视频的
对吧你不是不想当家吗
我不懂点
你不是我都会放错吧
我先不放错我先评论
你像我这种就是一只是不主吧
我其实每次发短视频的时候
我都很天心地把这个
视频的
要点金具你要学的关键之间
都跟你爹出来了
你看一看看完以后
你我自己的心得提供
你去评价吗
对吧
你让别人看见
也无所谓
但是你会发现这种系统
你像这个春日上春术
每天都必须写十一只
不是要写好
就是要写
我就是要完成这么一个动作
然后的话呢
也等家40年写的15卷组
那你看你像我呢
来短视频才6年了
每天呢我就
故意做炒
故意做不好
炒啥意思
你好我是个拿
说过每次拍短片就说
90分钟
拿起手就拍
我根本就不准备
我是真的不准备
就是为了拍插
为什么你找为什么吗
各位你想想
拍五分钟
我关门力了
我这个设计的半天
我出来以后那个播放量就一定高吗
不一定吧
那我还用心鼓半天
最后这样那么
就是播放量那么差
那多得啥呀
对不对
所以你会发现我到过来
来我随不然拍
拍吧以后播放量差
我根本就不在那后播放量
对吧
无所谓
五分钟十分钟拍的吗
你还有啥要求啊
没什么要求
但是你会发现万一有意调火了
随不而拍的呢
你就说表不调不
对不对
先从一个最简单的许就开始
我先做一个火程
慢慢做习惯了
而我在加量加5个火程
然后再加10个火程
我的短视频就是这么来的
第三条
很有意思啊
你要确认自己的身份
我不是拍短视频的
我们也像不是拍短视频
我是个问华人
我不过就是把我一些想法
一些输出
就一些想法输出来的
也就是什么播放量的
什么点赞率呀
这种文化人是吧
好人谁关注播放量
播放量
这什么呀
我就是一个文化
哇你知道吗
这个东西就会面移
什么叫免疫呢
你比如说你真的会有一道一些黑粉
他比较是拍短视频的
还带人就输你一页
一页说不了
但是你是文化人
你是文化人你看不到时候
你就会有一种去高底下的态度
就是呀
就好像几个立核吧
你就会联名的
就像有个级纓纓把它聪明和
哦哦哦,我忘教
你会和级纓纓纓吗
你不会呀
你会觉得这个级纓纓很可愛吗
不对
你想我前两天拍特使平
当那天我想找到后来
就和大家聊天嘛
我一边包历子我一边和大家聊
哎呦这个好再下回了
我看好多人在下面
就留言啊
你一边抢户
然后一边是东西
这是怎么怎么怎么怎么的
哎呦
我一点蒙
我说我和我的朋友们一边聊天一边吃东西
怎么呢
哎呦我突然就反映完了
一定是
我有点的糖土和深废的知识
什么呀让他们认为我是老师
那我要告他们其实我只是和朋友们聊天啊
算了算了
就让他们误会吧
所以因为你咱们
这个拖延传不顺的问题
这是大脑育生去来他罢了
那我们怎么解决呀
最好的方法就不要重申理一下
帮上腿
我又要努力
然后又要扣骨
然后我最后做完结果又不太好
最好的方法是什么
是站在山上
我是个文化的
每次国内小气势
然后找个很试的
撲很
很试的撲很长得起来
然后会下去